I'm getting better.
Uh,
hopefully I'll fight.
first quarter.
When did you get your shoulder surgery?
So I got it in like late March.
What was it?
Um,
labor them.
Uh,
but it was actually,
yeah,
labor rotator cuff I think,
but my rotator cuff was just fine.
Um,
and it's,
it's kept me out for a while,
but the whole time I've been,
um,
and it was actually after being on the podcast last time I'm talking about
bullying.
It's like,
how can we make a difference in,
there was such a response from Jerry Jerry,
like community saying,
let's do something here that also,
let's make a difference here in the United States of bullying.
How can you use it?
How can you prevent billing pulling?
What do you think?
I've always said that one of the best ways is teach people to actually fight.
Yeah.
I think that,
well,
a lot of bullies are hugely insecure and if they just learned how to fight,
they wouldn't act like that.
Right.
I think,
I think martial arts is going to be a tool.
So what we want to do this year is,
is to get into a hundred martial arts academies.
Um,
with a bullying prevention curriculum.
A lot of people don't know that 160,000 kids in the United States alone,
160,000 kids every day,
skip school,
skip school because of bullying.
That's 3 million school days last a year,
or sorry,
a month,
3 million school days,
lost a month.
And then I started digging into it because Oklahoma's become home now and like
28.9% of the students deal with depression that's debilitating.
That affects them for two weeks or more school to,
I mean,
depression,
addiction,
suicides in school,
shootings are all through the roof.
And you know,
it's the suicide rate that you said.
So,
so insane in Oklahoma fit.
This is the at risk youth,
um,
behavior survey and they say that 15.4 no,
15.1% of the students are dealing with suicidal ideation,
like seriously considering suicide.
And then 7.4,
7.4% of the students had attempted suicide,
attempted it.
I was one of those kids.
I was one of those kids in it's seven out of a hundred kids have attempted
suicide,
just an Oklahoma schools.
And that,
that,
that goes around the country to around that 6%,
8%.
I was on a bullying prevention summit in San Antonio with congressman or a US
representative will Hurd.
He brought me in and to speak with Maureen Molek and Maureen.
Um,
she has a foundation called David's legacy.
She started it because her son in San Antonio was getting ridiculed in cyber
bullied relentlessly.
You know,
whenever we were growing up,
bullying would end at 3:00 PM.
Right,
because you're out of school.
But now it just increases because kids aren't in school,
they aren't in class.
And so,
so that's whenever they can really take off and start bullying.
Well,
David had over 300 comments of people,
uh,
that were just brutally cyberbullying them.
A ton of them are calling for a suicide.
Um,
it went on for weeks and weeks.
They moved them from schools.
He attempted suicide and at once or twice,
but his third time,
his third time,
you're successful.
And I'm very proud of Maureen.
Uh,
very proud of her because she got a law passed called David's law.
David's laws about cyberbullying.
Uh,
we want to see if we can get that into Oklahoma.
What is the law?
So the law basically Maureen's family was told basically at school,
the school was good to them.
They were trying to make a difference,
but they're basically saying their hands were tied,
their hands are tied from,
from doing anything about it because it was an overwhelming response of
students.
I mean 300 students,
and then it was off school property and it was online.
So there they said their hands were tied.
Well,
now,
um,
the law basically brings into effect that law enforcement and the schools can
get involved off the school campus and they can look into the cyber bullying and
they can take action against it.
So it basically just means,
hey,
this is serious.
Um,
and,
and it's not okay.
Um,
and we're going to stand up and do something about it.
Texas,
I'm proud of Texas.
My home state,
um,
they passed it 33 to zero.
No one voted against it.
Um,
and it's really great.
We're,
we're working with a state representative named Collin Walkie.
I'm in Oklahoma,
um,
and,
uh,
a judge,
Trevor Pemberton.
And then there's this principal named,
it's Kinda sounded like a joke last week.
It was a MMA fighter with a politician.
We went to dinner with a politician,
a judge in a high school principal,
you know,
MMA fighter.
What brought us all together,
you know,
it was,
it was bullying prevention.
Um,
but,
uh,
debris on Davis.
She's the high school principal of Edmond North.
It's one of the biggest and one of the best public schools in Oklahoma.
Um,
and in the last nine years of her working in public schools,
she's been in nine funerals of kids that have all committed suicide.
And,
um,
it's,
uh,
it's just on the rise in such a brutal way.
And one of the things that really touched my heart and wanted me to get into to
this like,
Hey,
we've fight for the forgotten.
We're always going to be focused on the pygmies.
Uh,
we're working with even expanding into the,
in Uganda,
we're working with the pygmy king of the Botswana pygmies and Uganda.
Um,
we're looking to do land,
water and food initiatives among them,
but there's kids in our own community right here that feel forgotten.
Um,
and whenever I was a kid sitting at the lunch table by myself,
getting pelted in the back of the head with chuck and spit wads food fist,
um,
when kids were pulling up my shirt and slap my belly and twist and my nipples in
front of the girls and acting like they're hitting me with a harpoon,
you know,
cause I'm the size of a whale and all this stuff,
it and,
and telling me,
you should just kill yourself,
telling me you should just kill yourself.
You're worthless.
You're nothing.
I mean,
I,
I felt forgotten,
um,
and thought,
you know,
I am worthless and I should just kill myself and dealt with that over and over
and over.
And now the kids are taken action on that in such an incredible way that we've
got to stand up and do something.
And so we're,
we're partnering.
And,
uh,
I'm really excited.
Um,
we are hopefully getting them to a hundred martial arts academies this year to
equip them with bullying prevention curriculum.
Uh,
it's called heroes and waiting and you know,
uh,
a real inspiration to me.
There's two things.
Um,
there's a ted talk called the psychology of evil.
Oh,
I'll text you that link.
It's,
it's incredible,
but it's the psychology of evil and it's by getting with Philip Zimbardo or
something,
um,
and in there he kind of coins a term called heroes and waiting Philipson Bardot.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
then you,
you with the on it video that you did be the hero of your own movie,
you know,
be the hero of your own movie.
Um,
I love that.
I love that,
that,
that you've spoken out and said that about people.
You can be the hero of your own movie.
Well,
rose,
in waiting the curriculum that we developed with century and Maya,
which is the martial arts industry association,
um,
it's all about teaching kids.
It's,
it's bullying prevention,
but it's also character development.
So that is what prevents bullying.
Yeah,
absolutely.
The only people that bully or people with weak characters.
Yeah.
And kids that are usually
there's something wrong at home.
Right.
You know a lot of these kids that are bullies usually getting abused at home or
either by an older brother or by their dad or cousins or whoever the fuck it is,
it's,
and then they're taking it out on someone who they feel is weaker than them.
Right.
This is one of the reasons why I think martial arts is so important for young
men because I mean we know from our experience in gyms when you're dealing with
like high level martial artists on a regular basis,
like there is some of the nicest,
friendliest fucking people you're ever going to meet because they don't have any
insecurities.
I mean,
and whatever insecurities they have,
they get out in the gym to get out through training.
They get all of their frustrations.
They don't have all this pent up fucked up energy that a lot of kids have.
Like kids.
Kids are always dealing with existential angst and the,
their whole life is just this weird ball of confusion and hormones.
And you know,
the,
the whole idea of life itself is so confusing.
Then anytime they have any sort of control over anything they exercise it.
Whether it's control over another kid or control over,
you know,
throwing a rock through a window or they don't know what the fuck they're doing.
You know,
they have all this pent up fucked up energy and pain and I,
I think that so many of them are just severely lacking in guidance and
discipline and just those things alone.
D Guidance and discipline and also the lessons that you learned from martial
arts that you can overcome things that you can get better at things and that
when you feel like quitting and you don't,
you actually grow and learn like your experiences like training with Shawn and
Solow just like that.
It's,
it's one of the things in made you said a champion,
I mean training with people that are like,
it all started with my dad and having that when I was a kid ass.
You know,
you're so fortunate because of that.
I mean,
and those experiences are what shaped you into the person that you are today.
And a lot of people don't get those experiences and unfortunately they act and
disgraceful ways.
And this is what we're talking earlier.
I mean to
bring it all back to like what is martial arts and art is martial arts shit
talking and thrown dollies or is his martial arts really competing in one of the
most difficult endeavors in all of all of the world of sports?
Well,
so I came from a wrestling background and I believe that is without a doubt a
martial art.
Yes,
it is for sure.
Set of martial art percent and then,
um,
in my coaches and one of the most important martial.
Absolutely.
And one of the toughest to do one of the toughest without a doubt.
And then,
um,
but then coming into rough gym,
I mean,
Academy in school,
it,
it started teaching me like the martial arts principles.
We didn't really talk about that so much.
Um,
in,
uh,
in wrestling it teaches you that,
that naturally the hard work because it thins the flock pretty quick.
If you can't,
you can't cut it.
But then what are the six blades like?
So,
so Solow,
he,
uh,
his logo,
it's the star and uh,
he considers the mineral middle,
the spirit of the Samurai,
and then there's six blades to the star.
Um,
and they stand for six different values.
Uh,
loyalty,
respect,
honor,
discipline,
attitude and family.
And those are the core principles inside,
inside the Children's program at my academy.
Uh,
and sort of just the,
there it is right there.
The,
uh,
it's a very famous logo.
Yes,
it is.
And I have right here.
I carry it with me everywhere I am.
Yeah.
That's it.
But,
um,
you know,
besides for the,
the,
those are the,
the core values and then,
you know,
being a forever student and a dedicated your life to learning and bettering
yourself.
I mean,
these things that martial arts gives you,
I just,
I,
you know,
there are certain areas and other sports that they give you a piece of that,
but nothing is like martial arts,
you know,
for me,
everything I know,
I've learned through martial arts.
There's,
yeah.
I think what you're saying that there's,
there's other sports that teach you discipline.
Like Jasmine,
if you become a long distance runner,
there's,
there's discipline involved in that.
It's going to build up your character,
but it's not specifically emphasized the way it is in martial arts.
And so I,
I've been looking into and researching and we're partnering with century.
We're partnering with Zebra,
we're partnering with Gameness,
we're partnering with,
um,
Souplesse.
Uh,
I don't know if you've seen the Bulgarian bags and the throwing dummies and the
gladiator wall.
We're partnering with them because Gladiator Wall,
glad your well is the wood that is,
you can hang on it and you can do all sorts of stretching and different bars.
The level almost looks like a ladder.
Actually,
Jamie,
if he could pull up,
fight for the forgotten.work,
um,
I've actually got something to show in their soup.
Less on there,
which should give a shout out to the cash APP too.
Oh my gosh.
The cash APP is one of my favorite sponsors,
has done an incredible thing in donating $5 to fight for the forgotten.
Every time someone signs up and uses the code word Joe Rogan Yup.
Which is pretty amazing.
Thousands of dollars from that.
They've built two wells,
more of them or more coming in January,
we're starting to implement,
but um,
cash app came to me and we were trying to do a $50,000 fundraiser to drill a
deep,
deep well,
um,
in Tanzania for the Masai Warriors.
Um,
and we're going to do that with water boys,
which is Chris Lungs Foundation,
Chris long police for the Philadelphia Eagles.
He won the Superbowl,
donate his entire salary.
Really great guy,
climbed Mount Kilimanjaro with him and we are partnering together to help this
village to get 7,500 people clean water.
So it's about $6 per person.
I started posting about that and Gary Mcmanus from cash app hit me up and was
just like,
hey,
we want to do something big with you guys.
Um,
and we already had another $50,000 donor that was being anonymous and cash up
came in and said,
hey,
we're going to match that $50,000 match you have.
So cash APP gives $50,000 if we could raise 50,000.
And so we ended up raising 50,000,
52,000,
600,
$25,
and then,
uh,
and then it was tripled.
So it,
it came out to being 150,
2,625 and a cash app gave us $50,000 because they believe in the mission and
vision of fight for the forgotten.
They believe in you.
They believe in this community.
Um,
and me and I absolutely love cash app.
The,
in fact,
on this crowdfunding tournament we're doing,
um,
on the website fight for the forgotten.org/heroes.
We're doing a heroes in waiting crowdfunding tournament.
And so we're inviting in a hundred martial arts academies in a hundred
individuals to help us raise 4,000,
$200.
So yeah,
we're doing it through December 31st.
So we're given us quite a bit of time,
but what we're going to be doing is the crowdfunding tournament is going to fund
a wells.
So we will transform a community with a $4,200,
and it will equip their martial arts academy with a bullying prevention
curriculum.
So they'll just amazing by the way.
Yeah.
Everything that you could ever ask for,
uh,
to help,
pass that knowledge along and increase your program,
you know,
help your school,
bring more kids in,
uh,
make a bigger impact.
Um,
so not only are you helping the kids,
but then you're also raising money,
uh,
inside the academy to help towards,
um,
you know,
the fight for the forgotten.
Yeah.
And uh,
it's,
it's gonna be a thing where,
so it's,
there's 12 weeks of Mat chat topics and I love it because he rose in waiting and
talks about,
hey,
everyone is a hero in waiting.
And what is a hero?
A hero is someone who sees a need and takes action immediately.
And so we're teaching the kids that,
hey,
guess what?
87% of the time.
Whenever you see bullying and you say something,
it can be as easy as,
hey,
that's not kind.
Or you include the person that's being bullied into your group.
Hey,
come over here.
Um,
within five seconds,
the bullying stops.
87% of the time.
All you have to do is say one thing,
87% of the time,
almost nine out of 10 times you can shut down bullying whenever you see it
happening.
Because here's the problem.
Whenever people think you're,
when you see bullying happening,
a lot of times you might think you're an innocent bystander,
but,
but your body language and you being around and involved in the bully,
seeing that he takes you being that you're a silent supporter,
so you're not an innocent bystander.
You're now involved when you see it.
And so you're being a silent supporter if you're not standing up and doing
something about it.
And so we're doing this competition and whoever,
whoever's the top crowdfunding a team is going to get there,
Jim renovated by Zebra,
they're going to get $10,000 worth a zebra mats.
Um,
century is going to come in and do $10,000 worth of a gear.
They're going to do gloves,
uh,
head gear,
um,
sparring equipment,
shields the Bob the dummy souplesse is going to do the,
the Bulgarian bag,
uh,
throwing dummy.
Um,
and then the top individual fundraiser is going to get a free home gym from
Zebra and century gear.
Uh,
Bella toward,
just let me know last night that whoever is the top fundraising individual is
going to get flown out,
all inclusive,
um,
to,
uh,
to the January 26th,
the heavyweight Grand Prix finale,
uh,
between and Ryan Beta forum at the forum in La.
So you're going to get,
they're going to get three nights of hotel rooms are going to get their airfare
paid for.
And uh,
so basically what fight for the free is trying to do is raise $420,000
throughout the rest of the year.
And what we'll be able to do with that is hopefully drill equivalent to 100
water wells were served 30,000 people minimum.
Hopefully we'll be around 45,000 people with clean water.
And then,
um,
it's,
it's pretty easy if people go and hit sign up.
Um,
Jamie,
if you could just hit the link.
It's a,
it's sign up.
It,
we're trying to make it really fun to tell people how to get to it.
It's fight for the forgotten.org forward slash.
Heroes.
It's forward slash heroes.
And then here,
whenever they go down,
you can hit become a fundraiser.
And whenever you become a fundraiser,
you can either create a team,
which we did with Lovato's a couple nights ago.
Um,
you can hit join a team.
So if a team's already created,
you can join that team where if you're an individual martial artists or just
someone that's passionate about the cause,
you can hit a start fundraising as an individual.
Awesome.
Um,
and then we're going to have a top 10 prizes.
Uh,
basically like prize packs.
The top crowdfunding team is going to get a championship belt,
a fight for the forgotten championship belt.
Uh,
two through 10 are going to get championship trophies.
And then anyone that hits the goal of $4,200 is going to get a fight for the
forgotten gold metal for hitting the goal.
Um,
but the,
uh,
if,
if you actually click out of that and then scroll down,
Jamie,
you can actually see how it's kind of started a little bit more,
but there's a already a few teams while there's four teams now that have signed
up and some of our res,
we haven't announced it yet,
so,
um,
there's team Lovato down there,
there's,
and it,
what it will do is we'll show the top team so you can track it and make it
competitive so that you can go on there and make a comment whenever you donate.
Um,
but basically,
I guess martial arts and more,
uh,
I do know them if you click on their page.
Um,
it's a guy out of South Carolina,
sorry,
North Carolina,
Jacksonville.
Um,
and he just got hit by the hurricane brutally.
he can't go back into his home for another year,
a year,
year.
He can't go back into his home.
He's living in the academy.
Why a year?
His homeowner's association set,
it's going to be like a year of clean up,
fix everything,
fix everything.
That's what it's predicted to be.
But he said at $4,200,
he wants to teach his community,
um,
is as James,
right.
And,
uh,
he,
he's wanting to,
you know,
teach the kids that,
hey,
we're still heroes in waiting.
We can still make a difference in our community with bullying prevention and
globally with a community that needs clean water.
And so that's what we're trying to do is make a difference in both places.
Drill the wells and equip the Martial Arts Academy with bullying prevention.